in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 1, on which we commemorate the procession
of the precious cross.
On the first of the month we celebrate the memory of the procession of the holy and
life-giving cross in Constantinople.
On this day, it was customary in Constantinople to take the relic of the precious cross from
the imperial palace and carry it to St. Sophia's, escorted by a crowd of priests and deacons
who sensed it along the way.
They stopped first at the small baptistry, where the blessing of the waters was solemnized,
and they placed the cross on the holy table of St. Sophia's.
From the great church, they made a circuit of the city during the following days, quarter
by quarter until the eve of the Dormition in order to purify the air and protect the people
of the capital from the epidemics that spread more quickly in those days of hot weather.
After having thus assured the health and comfort of all who venerated it with faith, the
Holy Cross was then taken back to the palace.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.